[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday July
26th and hello to our new viewers
welcome this is Brotherhood 2.0
sometimes we put stuff on our heads it's
nobody in there it's been a little bit
difficult for me to stop doing my happy
dance lately I'm out at the store and
I'm doing my habits and walk into the
street now do my evidence I'm in the
shower and I'm doing my happy dance even
though it's really dangerous because
there's no traction in my tub and that
could really turn bad it could turn bad
for those of you who've never seen it I
just did my happy dance a little while
ago and I caught him on camera so here
it is yes
it's excellent aerobic exercise I think
that everybody knows why I've been doing
my happy dance but if not just go to the
front page of YouTube and on there you
will see me looking out from the front
page of YouTube from the little square
Axio Akio Accio Osseo OshKosh B'gosh EO
deathly hallows has been featured on the
front page of YouTube and has been
watched over 200,000 times 200,000 times
now I know what you're all thinking
you're thinking Hank it's really great
that you were featured on the front page
of YouTube I'm I'm happy for you but
what is the price of YouTube fame the
price is that for every 100 views your
video gets there will be one comment and
when there aren't very many comments you
can take them each individually and they
seem lovely and occasionally annoying
but when there are 2,000 of them they
start to take shape and it's a shape
kind of like this and while this nice
bell curve at the top you have lots of
people being very nice you also have
these two extremes and when people are
either being way too mean or way too
nice simple a comment from each section
would be something like this you have
you're gay you're gay but you're funny
cool video lot of miles off you're a
friggin genius and please let me have
your babies strange thing is that when
you have a big sample like this every
person sees it very differently for
example your mom will see this
whereas your wife will see this and you
yourself will see this so when the unit
becomes kind of just a very stressful
thing it feels like half the people are
saying that you're gay and half the
people want you to have their babies I
imagine I don't have to point out the
irony here but in either case your wife
is upset but I've been able to temper it
I've been able to see that most people
are just being very nice and supportive
if I can just shave off the people who
either want to be my girlfriend or want
me to get a girlfriend then I can just I
can be happy and when they're not saying
that pronounced Accio or akio wrong
which fine yes I did it's nice it's
Pleasant the people are very cool him
the people are very jokes um yes I do
think it would be jokes if we use the
word jokes instead of jokes whenever we
said jokes I mean I think it would be
cool if we said the word jokes instead
of cool every time we set the word cool
John I'm glad you're feeling better and
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]